IGN gave Call of Duty Modern Warfare 3's
single player campaign a four out of 10
some people are calling this the worst
single player campaign in COD history
and apparently it only takes about 4
hours to finish which is nuts because
people are also complaining about it
being mundane or boring in fact this IGN
review refers to it as underbaked rehash
cobbled together for multiplayer parts
and referred to it as mundane Warfare
which is a little bit funny the IGN
reviewer called it the worst card
campaign they've ever played called it
shallow and dull and I know a lot of
people are going to reply to this be
like Call of Duty campaigns have always
been bad I strongly disagree there are
some very good campaigns in Call of Duty
history in fact I look forward to them
so it's a real bummer that apparently
this one is not up to scratch